the people for the ethical treatment of
animals just put out a video the video
was trying to persuade people that if
you go vegan you'll have a better sex
life it's better for your you know blood
flow or whatever it's a video of people
molesting fruit that says want to spice
things up in the bedroom there's people
with like a kiwi and a pepper chili
peppers will have you hot and heavy in
no time the squirt of OJ can increase
blood flow to important organs
I'm going to look away from this get a
load of this ink to increase your libido
avocados well this is disgusting we'll
give you the stamina to keep going go
vegan your partner will thank you
select molesting a cantaloupe and now
someone lay this just stop it stop it
stop it turn it off
this uh
this is the values that we're looking at
now first of all it's not very
persuasive to me
when that we're told to adopt the you
know adopt our ethical system
and we're being told that by people who
are molesting fruit